let's talk about loaders loaders are
awesome they were introduced in
honeycomb but are available as part of
the support library so you can take
advantage of them when supporting
earlier platform releases loaders are
essentially the best practice
implementation for asynchronous data
loading within an activity or fragment
so when you create a loader
it creates an async task to load data on
the background thread it then syncs with
the UI thread when the initial loading
is complete and can be set up to monitor
the underlying data and deliver any
updates to the UI thread as well Beth
still all that work you did adding a
content provider to your database pays
off right now
with the cursor loader the cursor loader
is an implementation of the async task
loader specifically designed to query
content providers and return a cursor
which you can then bind directly to a UI
it will automatically update that cursor
whenever the underlying content provider
changes based on changes to the
underlying database and it will
reconnect to the last returned cursor
after being recreated along with the
host activity after a configuration
change that means you won't have to re
query data just because the device was
rotated so the cursor loader handles all
of your cursor management and background
thread creation UI thread
synchronization and datasource
monitoring if you chose not to use
content providers you chose poorly
but still you can take advantage of
loaders you just need to create your own
loader by extending a think task loader
directly you can find out more in the
instructor notes below